vous souvenez qu'il ya quelques temps je
vous avais proposé pour fêter les 200
mille abonnés de vous envoyer un cadeau
j'avais créé pour ça un formulaire sur
lequel vous répondiez et après vous
envoyer un courrier alors oui on a reçu
quelques lettres 1
on a reçu ça on a reçu ça on a reçu bien
sûr tout ça c'est un carton qui est
rempli de l'être également
les courriers vont être envoyés à partir
de demain et j'ai pas encore ouvert
toutes les lettres parce qu'il ya
beaucoup trop de l'être par contre en
les ouvrant on commence à trouver des
choses alors mélanie qui s'est tapé les
deux mille premières ouvertures m'a mis
de côté tous vos mots et les je crois
qu'il ya des cadeaux aussi et je vais
découvrir ça là maintenant alors bien
sûr je pourrais pas lire les deux tout
le monde à la caméra mais je les lirais
tout ça c'est sûr ça prendra un petit
peu de temps mais c'est tellement cool
de recevoir du courrier voilà déjà on a
du fun à ça c'est moi ça c'est à malo
qui est devenu un châle ou ou vache ni
ce choix en black story trop fort alors
ça c'est le black story mort de rire que
je n'ai pas alors la personne qui m'a
envoyé ça excuse moi je j'ai pas ton nom
sous les yeux n'est pas de la petite
étiquette avec mais déjà merci et dans
toutes les vidéos que je tourne chez moi
dans le bureau qui a chez moi à côté de
la bibliothèque
il ya un black so ri parce que j'adore
ce jeu et ça c'est la version mort de
rire que je ne connais pas mais merci
parce qu'en fait à la base c'est moi qui
suis censé vous envoyer un petit cadeau
en plus et là je reçois apparemment des
gros trucs genre invisible de damien
savina damiens est un grand magicien
c'est un grand créateur et j'ai eu la
surprise immense en ouvrant une des
lettres de voir un petit mot avec sa où
il y avait marqué il n'y a pas de raison
qui est que toi qu'il fasse des cadeaux
il m'envoyait un superbe numéro de
l'acte il a créé deux bacs volante
merci beaucoup damien merci et là tout
le monde sait de quoi on peut faire
voler des vagues
qu'est ce que c'est que ça du chocolat
suisse alors les suisses vous avez eu un
point commun vous m'avez envoyé beaucoup
de chocolat et beaucoup d'argent
trop d'argent il faut échoué j'appelle
les parents trouvaient des 50 centimes
on a trouvé des 1 euro et des 2 euros
c'était pour acheter les timbres retour
alors ça c est très compliqué en fait
parce que vous imaginez on a reçu 7000
est 7500 halle est là pour l'instant
c'est compliqué d'aller acheter des
tonnes pour tout le monde bref on fait
de notre mieux et on est monté aussi
jusqu'à un billet de 20 euros à billets
de vingt balles quand même alors le
biais d'un jeu l'hérault mis dans une
enveloppe et j'ai marqué un mot à la
personne en disant non on va pas prendre
les 20 euros mais c'était parce que 20
euros pour un timbre c'est beaucoup
quand même
je sais je sais pas en suisse
apparemment ça passe bien mais merci
mathilde pour ce petit billet montaleau
ça je ne sais pas comment je dois le
prendre parce qu'on voit bien que c'est
un pochoir
du coup c'est quoi le message c'est que
si on faisait un pochoir avec moi en
taille réelle ça donnerait ça je suis
trop petit c'est ça je prends très mal
le dessin cher fabien olicard je n'ai
pas pu timbre et mon enveloppe néanmoins
vous trouverez ci joint un coupon
réponse qui permettra de me renvoyer
mal-être j'espère que ça suffira bien
avoue simon écoute si mon jeu je ne sais
pas je vais découvrir ton coupon réponse
reste le mot coupon réponse ça me paraît
compliqué le petit cerf de victor on
pourrait y mettre cette carte dans une
de tes vidéos à venir derrière toi par
exemple ça me fait super plaisir
quelque chose me dit que là tu es bien
servi tellement plaisir d'avoir autant
de courriers mon palais mental oh tu
t'es créer un peu pâle et mentale à base
de trappes de train comme on appelle ça
comment fait on appel ça mélanie des
trains non mais oui d'un baby la banque
saderat avait dit c'est les petits ont
dit pas un petit train train électrique
un train en modèle réduit en fait il
n'ya pas un nom pour ça je sais pas si
tu avais déjà ça et que tu t'en un effet
un ballet mental vous savez comment ça
concerne le palais mental et du coup que
tu es en train de le refaire en réel
quoi qu'il en soit je trouve ça très
drôle mais plutôt malin aussi ou un
livre aussi alors ça c'est énorme aussi
à temps je crois que d'un petit mot avec
j'ai reçu de la part de yann via amazon
un bouquin d'énigmes et mer
beaucoup gagnent déjà merci
qu'arrive-t-il demande à annabelle 6x
détruits y lorsque x et y sont une seule
et même expression en d'autres termes
supposons que x détruisent x cela
signifie-t-il que le robot x se
détruiraient lui même c'est exactement
ça confirme à didier charles ces robots
sont appelés suicidaire alors maintenant
seriez vous trouvez un robot x qui soit
suicidé à mon système on prévoit un ca
évidemment dit alexandre nous savons
déjà comment trouver un x tel que x créé
x donc dx se détruira lui même eh bien
on coupe à didier charles 6 x créé
lui-même alors dx détruira x mais ça ne
veut pas dire que dx détruira dx et
c'est pourtant ce qu'on cherche à oui
biensur miroir derrière alexandre alors
quelle est la solution correcte
voilà donc je te remercie yann on va
bien se marrer je pense qu'on va faire
vu cette énigme là durant tout 2010 est
beaucoup d'origami gryffondor joli truc
joli c est ce qu il ya des petits maux
de dents que j'ai pas regardé quand je
vous dis qu'on trouve de l'argent 2h52
scotché à mini jeux de cartes en
porte-clés c'est pas énorme ça aussi ça
lui désolé pas de timbres français en
belgique je t'ai mis de quoi les payer
merci adrien apparemment pas de papiers
chez toi donc du coup tu déchires
délivre un p4
donc c'est bien dégueulasse ça il faut
que je fasse voir ça quand même un psy
très étrange de me faire ce dessin là
pour toi fabien olicard continuté vidéo
alors écoute
déjà je voulais te remercier toi qui
m'as fait ce cadeau je suis c'est
peut-être un chapeau mais même pas en
faire assez
c'est à y avait les 20 euros dedans
d'accord c'est là qu'ils avaient les
vingt balles ok j'ai donc le maroc on a
renvoyé était là dedans d'accord et et
en plus de ça alors ça c'est toujours
très désastreux pour mon ego c'est à
dire que tu as réussi à faire deux
fautes d'orthographe dans mon nom de
famille et entre amis de zèle au lieu
d'un et pas de d c'est
voilà bon ben je te re en fait on va
garder les 20 euros merci beaucoup
d'avoir envoyé tous ces petits mots ces
petits cadeaux c'était pas lui qui a la
balle je vous demandais juste une
enveloppe pour vous glisser votre cadeau
vous l'envoyez vous avez été très très
nombreux m'envoyer sa merci beaucoup
vous avez été aussi très très nombreux à
m'envoyer des mails et des commentaires
et des tweets des messages sur facebook
pour savoir si vous avez encore le temps
pour me poser des questions sur le sur
le cadeau pour plein de choses comme ça
j'ai répondu à aucun voilà ça c'est dit
aucun parce que vraiment on a eu dix
mille inscrits pour pour le jeu donc
j'ai reçu peut-être 5000 6000 messages
comme ça me posant des questions j'avais
essayé d'être le plus clair possible
désolé s'il en a qu'ont vu que
dernièrement dans leurs spams le mail
que j'avais envoyé ou d'autres concon
pas pu envoyer la lettre avant il
fallait forcément que je pose des
limites puisque sinon je ne m'en sortais
pas de mon côté ça a été un taf énorme
de mettre tous en place il nous reste un
taf énorme pour tous renvoyés du coup
ceux qui donneront ce sera un collector
ça c'est sûr je vous le dis on fait les
envoie à partir de demain dans vos
enveloppes vous allez recevoir des
choses qui ressemble un petit peu à ça
et un petit peu à ça j'ai été le plus
vite possible parce que je sais que vous
allez faire un arrêt sur image merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère que
ça vous a plu si c'est le cas leaké
abonnez vous et rendez vous demain à 17h
tchad
m
[Musique]